All my cars have
good stereos.
I mean, loud stereos.
You've got to feel the music.
Hey, do some hopping.
A 30 year ban
on cruising in
National City is over.
In just two weeks, many men
and women are planning to join the
low and slow crews in the streets
of National City.
How's it going?
My name is Vincent Palacios.
I grew up in Paradise Hills and
moved here in 1976.
I have a low rider shop, doesn't
take care of all the bills, but it's
an enjoyment to see people drive
away like they got a new toy
on Christmas.
All my kids have all
cruised with me.
My youngest son helps
me at the shop and is
like really involved in
the little writing community.
This one doesn't hop.
I mean, I can play with it, but it
doesn't hop. Not meant for hopping.
Yeah.
She's never been in a low rider in
her life.
Oh, my god.
Now she's going to get stuck.
You're going to see a bunch of other
cars like this, so go there. Uh,
y'all know the address?
I can type it in my phone? I think
if you look up Chicano Park, it
should. Okay.
Chicano Park.
We'll see you guys tomorrow in
Yeah, bring, bring, bring this girl.
All right.
Back in '82,
the low riding, yeah, it was
a lot more fun.
This whole area right
here on your right would just get
packed with people, all
the low riders would park in this
parking lot, and it would
get crazy over here.
So low riding was really born,
you know, after World War II.
And there was a sort of rise in
car culture activities and
cruising and demolition derbies
and custom culture.
Chicanos have definitely been
key in popularizing low riding.
But I think you begin to see in the
nineties, particularly here in
L.A., like anti cruising
ordinances, cracking down
right on cruising, cracking
down on if a certain amount
of black men or brown men would be
hanging out in the street.
We call those gang injunctions,
which they could be gang members or
could just be a group of friends or
a club hanging out.
The police could use that to sort of
crack down.
So that's when you sort of see those
cruising ordinances really being put
into effect here.
It wasn't until like the nineties
the police started
harassing us.
They put signs up on Highland
Avenue and said
that cruising is prohibited
and they would actually measure
with a cigarette  pack.
If it was lower than a cigarette
pack, then you were
illegal.
Why pick on one style
of car or one
race?
It's unfair.
Big time.
I've grown up seeing the no cruising
ban and always wondering
why really was it banned and
why my dad's generation
of low riding wasn't able to express
themselves anymore.
I think one of the reasons about
like cruising is that it's sort of
slowing down traffic.
Just even during the pandemic, it
got shut down.
People that come and do the donuts
and motorcycles and then it became
this public nuisance.
Right. And so I think it's always a
tension.
I couldn't even tell you the age of
when I started going cruising.
It's been all my life.
It goes from
cruising with your dad and in the
back seat with your parents
to building model car kits.
This weekend is Chicano Park Day
coming up this Saturday, one
of the biggest events in San Diego
and the lowrider community.
After three years of either no
celebrations or a virtual one,
Chicano Park Day is back in full
force.
The ban on Highland,
it made Chicano Park even more
popular because
you know nobody wanted to go down
Highland because of the cops.
Straighten out, straighten out,
straighten out.
Okay, now straight.
Hey, did we get a good spot or what?
Chicano Park, that was the people's
park.
So cruising on Chicano Park,
that never stopped.
Chicano Park Day is really to
commemorate the fight all those
years ago, back in the seventies
to keep this park here.
If this park wasn't here, you want
to be able to show off your car or
your Chicano culture.
Tell me about that.
Oh, yeah.
This was kind of the epicenter in
San Diego for low riding.
So we enjoy coming out
here and, you know, we don't get
harassed or nothing.
It's beautiful out here.
Yeah. Awesome.
Thank you so much.
Good luck today. Okay.
I've only been going since
the late eighties.
I can tell you for sure,
because of the community it's
in, that community has really
evolved.
Today I think
what is different with cruising is
that lowriders are trying to work
with their local cities to sort
of end the anti cruising ordinances,
like they've been successful in
Sacramento, in San Jose,
and also in National City just
recently, which is out there by San
Diego.
But there's still a California
anti cruising ordinance that's
in existence.
So the work right now is to sort of
end the anti cruising ordinance
in California and then for local
cities to find a way
for lowriders to work with law
enforcement to have sort of
a cruising space
that is not a public nuisance.
We are off to go see Jovita and
Rabbit.
Rabbit, I've known probably
20, 30 years plus.
He used to be in a car club called
Amigos.
And then Jovita, she's more
of the person to talk to you about
the rebuild and National City.
How is Chicano Park?
Oh, crazy, crazy, crazy.
I mean.
Well, everybody's been craving it
for four years because of COVID.
It was even harder to walk down the
aisles and look at cars.
Mr. Rabbit.
Vincent.
You know, this one's a hard one to
get, right?
Yes, it is.
Especially after the mayor took them
all down. You know, people were
stealing 'em. Yeah.
They invite everybody over there,
and it becomes like a community
really fast.
Literally, we had papers
and questions, and we wrote down I
think number one was,
do we bring crime?
Do we cause
problems?
That's what we're trying to address.
So that
when we do go to like a community
event, that doesn't
happen no more.
You know, when we started
with, all we wanted to do was repeal
the ordinance.
Yeah, we got text messages
within seconds.
And regulation.
Regulation. Wow, you guys
did it. What a historical moment.
Well, you know, so my son's so
young, right?
So I've been, like, saving you all
the paper and little things
because he'll be able to brag or
whatever. My dad, you know, helped,
you know, repeal of, you know,
criminal cruising and all that
stuff.
Owning a car is like the American
dream, right?
Your house, your car.
And I think that low riding is a
great example to me, just like hip
hop, right? Like people use
culture to tell their stories.
Right. To mark space in the United
States. To say this is what makes
us unique.
Everybody to downtown Paradise
Hills. So we just thank you for this
sunny afternoon.
Ladies and gentlemen, let the
cruising begin.
For me, low riding
is just enjoying
going out on a nice day
and hanging out with my friends
and hearing great music.
It's a way of life.
I don't think low riding's ever
going to die in our family.
It's just something we've always
loved and enjoyed
expressing ourselves.